I've been a lifelong fan of the IMAX  experience and it's a real thrill to  have Forrest Gump being restored and  reformatted and I'm actually everyone  has a special moment in the movie that's  close to them and when you're in an IMAX  situation your special moment will be  magnified and you'll experience it very  differently  I'm a believer that there's all  different types of spectacle in movies  action visual effects which we have a  lot of in in Forrest Gump but I also  think that a spectacle too comes from  things like a close-up or a performance  whenever you're in an immersive  situation where the image of the movie  is taking up your complete peripheral  vision you're immersed in the movie and  to be immersed in the movie I think that  every scene becomes special and  spectacular that's the whole point of  being in a giant IMAX theater